despite common misconception social
media marketing isn't overly complex and
nor it is a casual undertaking after
immersing myself into social media
marketing for decade and exploring
various platforms such as blogs Facebook
LinkedIn Twitter Youtube and Instagram I
have crafted a structure step-by-step
process that you can apply to your
social media marketing Endeavors
adhering to the old age wisdom that
plans are nothing and plans is
everything having a solid social media
marketing plan is very very crucial
without it your attempts to leverage the
potential of social media networks might
end up being futile establishing a well
organized and comprehensive social media
marketing planning process significantly
boost your chances of success in this
Dynamic and evolving field so what are
the steps that you should take to thrive
in the social media marketing and where
should you start we will explore all
this in today's video but before we move
on and learn more about it I request you
guys that do not forget to hit the
Subscribe button and click the Bell icon
for future updates just a quick info
guys if you are aspiring to become a
digital marketer then simply learn has
got you covered simply learn has got
postgraduate program and digital
marketing in collaboration with purd
University you can become a certified
digital marketer from pu University you
will learn to create and promote your
own website via live Interactive
Learning you'll Master basic and
advanced digital marketing skills via
stend simulation plus there will be 10
plus case studies and 20 plus projects
like chart GPT and other AI tools and
also we will discuss 35 Plus DM tools
hurry up and join now the course link is
mentioned in the description box so guys
let us discuss the social media
marketing road map the first thing is to
identify a marketing problem so guys
identifying Market problem is a
foundational step in devising an
effective social media marketing
strategy it involves a comprehensive
evaluation of various aspects that may
hinder your business growth addressing
these issues strategically can pave the
way for successful social media
campaigns firstly consider the challenge
of inadequate brand awareness and
publicity if your target audience is not
familiar with your brand it's crucial to
focus efforts on increasingly visibility
through engaging cont content and
targeted campaigns next is the declining
sales from traditional Channel signals
that need shift in marketing approach
Embrace social media platforms to reach
a wider audience and explore new avenues
for sales if I talk about the third one
a decline in fresh leads also Demands a
reassessment of lead generation
strategies so that you have to utilize
social media expansive reach to attract
and convert potential customers if
Rising operating cost costs are
affecting profitability social media can
offer cost-effective Marketing Solutions
leveraging these platforms can optimize
resource allocation and enhance overall
efficiency customers defection due to
poor service also highlights the
importance of using social media as a
customer service tool address concerns
promptly and showcase positive
experiences to build loyalty lastly if
your content isn't generating desired
engagement refine your strategy analyze
audience preferences experiment with
content formats and encourage
interaction to increase shares and
engagement by pinpointing these
challenges you can tailor your social
media efforts to address specific needs
ensuring a more targeted and impactful
marketing strategy now let us move on to
our next one which is setting up social
media marketing objectives or goals in
the realm of social media marketing
setting clear goals defining objectives
and establishing measurable metrics are
crucial components of a strategic
approach let's delve into each aspect
the first one that is coming into my
mind is goals goals are Broad and
overachieving statements that articulate
when you aim to achieve through your
social media efforts for example
increasing brand awareness online this
goal provides a general direction
indicating a desire to enhance the
visibility and recognition of your brand
within the online space it sets a tone
for your social media strategy but lacks
the specificity needed for direct
measurement now let us move on to the
next one which is objectives objectives
are specific measurable and time bound
Milestone desire to achieve a broader
goal for example increase the number of
new fans on social media platforms by
20% within the next quarter or boast
post engagement by 15% over the next 6
months or achieve a 25% growth growth in
the web traffic from social media
channels in the next year these were the
certain examples which showcases what
are your objectives objectives break
down the broader goal into actionable
and measurable components they provide a
road map for achieving the overachieving
goal of increase brand awareness
offering clear targets and timelines the
next and the most important one is
metric metrics are quantifiable
parameters used to measure the
performance and success of a social
media efforts for example the number of
new fans or followers what is the post
engagement rate or growth percentage in
the web trffic metrics are specific data
points that help assess progress towards
objectives they provide tangible
numerical evidence of a social media
performance for the goal of increasing
brand awareness the choosen metrics
should align with the defined objectives
such as tracking the increase in
followers engagement rates and weest
weite traffic originating from social
platforms by aligning goals objectives
and metrics businesses create a
structured framework that not only
guides their social media activities but
also enables a systematic evaluation of
success or areas that may need
adjustment this disciplined approach
enhances the effectiveness of social
media marketing efforts and contributes
to the overall success of the digital
strategy now let us move on to our next
one which is very very important that is
conducting social media audit and
Analysis once you have established your
social media marketing destination it's
imperative to assess your current
position again to determine your
standing point before embarking on a
journey this evaluation process often is
concurrent with setting objectives is
analogous to recognizing that attempting
to reach the moon is futile if your
flying machine can even take off so what
are the areas where you can perform
audit and
Analysis so guys let us discuss each one
of them one by one the first one is
evaluating your current social media
presence assess the strength weaknesses
opportunities and threats which is SWAT
of your existing social media engagement
understand the current state of your
online presence to identify areas for
improvement next is analyzing competitor
strategies investigate social media
tactics and performance of your
competitors identify potential gaps or
weaknesses in their approach so that you
can capitalize on the third one is
understanding your audience and the
journeys study your customers exploring
demographics psychographics online
behaviors and historical preferences map
out customer Journeys through stages
like awareness interest consideration
purchase retention and advocacy an
essential aspect of this phase involves
keyword research a critical exercise to
discern what your customers are actively
searching for utilize tools like Google
AdWords Keyword Planner which
facilitates this process aiding in
identifying the key terms and phrases
that align with your audience interests
and online Behavior this is a
comprehensive evaluation which not only
informs your social media strategy but
also positions you to leverage
opportunities and address weaknesses
effectively the next one is develop a
social Brand Story like every other
facet of of online promotion the
initiation of social media marketing
commences with narrating your brand
stale in the digital era social branding
involves crafting a unique value
proposition and a unique story
proposition it revolves around
instigating a grassroot movements within
your communities and constructing a
lasting connection founding on trust and
affability to infuse a narrative to your
brand it's valuable to contemplate the
following the first one is what
principle and conviction does your brand
uphold next one can be how are your
brand narratives conveyed in the online
sphere third one could be in what ways
are your stakeholders especially
customers engaged in your brand social
narrative and finally you can also add
and think upon it that how is your brand
expressed through visually appealing
brand images profile descriptions and
cover photos optimized for social media
platforms so this way you're going to
develop a social brand story let's move
on to the next step which is selecting
social media marketing channels choose
the right social media marketing
platform this is a phase that demands
decisive choices although each social
platforms hold its own appeal attempting
to master all can lead to spreading
efforts thin and mastering n consider
these factors when determine the
suitable social channels for your brand
the first one is Facebook if I talk
about Facebook guys this is the largest
social network that is also highly
competitive Facebook ads often yield to
positive Roi compared to other online
advertising Avenues the next one can be
Twitter characterized by its con size
144 corre limit tweets are now featured
on Google search engine result page then
you can have Instagram and Tuma which
are popular light social networks
especially among teens and youths
emphasis on visual content and pop
culture the next next and the most
famous one is YouTube this is the second
largest search engine however video
production is resource intensive if we
talk about Pinterest known as the social
candy due to its preference for visually
appealing designs and images over the
23s of Pinterest users are female making
informed decisions about the platforms
aligning with your brand goals and
target audience is very very essential
rather than trying to be present on
every platform Focus Fus on mastering
the ones most relevant to your
objectives and audience demographics now
let's move on to the next one which is
social content creation and curation
after determining your social channel
the next step is crafting compelling
social content embracing at20 rule in
the content creation and integrating
best practices in both written and
visual content are key
considerations here are certain crucial
aspects to ponder upon the first one is
content creation
techniques develop skills in writing
photography videography design content
production and also ensure a harmonious
blend of engaging and diverse content
the next one is content curation
strategies employ effective methods to
filter and curate relevant content
suitable for sharing showcase a mix of
original and curated content to keep
your audience engaged third one is
consistency and frequency if I talk
about consistency and frequency it comes
under the calendar development maintain
a consistent and a regular schedule for
your content production and distribution
for the scene you can choose a calendar
development create content calendar
outlining keywords topics and content
types for distribution across various
social channels plan and organize
content to align with specific goals and
strategies by mastering the art of
content creation and curation you can
effectively engage your audience and and
build a robust online presence
establishing a Content calendar helps
maintain consistency ensuring that your
content aligns with your brand voices
and also resonates with your target
audience across different social media
platforms let's move to the next one
which is evaluate and quantify the
success how you are going to measure and
quantify your success and what are the
key metrics the Timeless saying is that
you cannot manage what you don't measure
which holds particular relevance in the
era of measurable Marketing in social
media marketing it's crucial to develop
a comprehensive set of key performance
indicators or kpis to assess performance
these are certain key metrics which we
have to discuss and these incompass a
variety of metrics let's discuss each
one of them one by one the first one is
the brand awareness metrics the reach
website visits page views fan growth
likes and and comment all come under
this section the next one is we have the
conversion metrics the sign up on leads
memberships trial purchases and the
actual purchases comes under this
section the next one is the engagement
metrics the comments shares retweets
downloads and participations in contests
come under this section and finally our
social advertising Matrix which is cost
per clicks cost per acquisition return
on advertising spend among others by
amalga gating these metrics you can
derive insights into your social media
marketing into return on investment the
ability to quantify success through
these indicators allows for informed
decision making enabling you to refine
and optimize your social media strategy
for better outcomes exploring social
media marketing Roi can be very fruitful
in evaluating and quantifying the
success measures so guys in conclusion
effective social media marketing Demands
a strategic planning consistent
execution from identifying challenges
and setting clear goals to selecting
platforms creating engaging content and
measuring Success Through key
performance indicators each step is
crucial author social media audit align
goals and audience understanding from
the foundation selecting the right
channels mastering content creation
maintaining consistency are very pivotal
measuring Success Through metrics allows
for evaluating return on investment and
refining strategies in this Dynamic
landscape adaptability continuous
Improvement and genuine audience
engagement are essential for sustained
success by prioritizing authentic
connection and staying ATT tuned to
Trends businesses can leverage social
media to enhance brand presence and also
Foster lasting customer relationships
with that said guys that was it for all
today's video I hope so you would have
enjoyed our today's video on social
media marketing road map staying ahead
in your career requires continuous
learning and upskilling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here